what's your perfect programming setup
what computer what operating system want
keyboard what editor yeah perfect is too
strong a worried its way to struggle
right of what I use by default I have a
at this point a 13-inch MacBook Air
which I used because it's kind of a
reasonable balance of the various things
I need I can carry it around it's got
enough computing horsepower screens big
enough to keyboards okay and so I
basically do most of my computing on
that um I have a big iMac in my office
that I use from time to time as well
especially when I need a big screen but
otherwise none tends not to be used as
much editor I use mostly Sam which is an
editor that Rob Pike wrote long ago at
the labs and at that
sorry to interrupt it does that proceed
v I post it post dates both VI and Emacs
it is derived from Rob's experience with
Edie and VI Oggy
that's the original UNIX editor o dated
probably before you were born so what's
actually what's the history of editors
can you can you briefly this is your fan
I used Emacs I'm sorry to say so I'm
sorry to come out with that but what's
what's the kind of interplay there yeah
so in ancient ancient times like call it
the first time sharing systems going
back to what we're talking about there
were editors there was an editor on CT
SS that I don't even remember what it
was called a little it might have been
edit where you could type text program
text and it would do something or
document text if it save then I save it
you could edit it you know the usual
thing that you would get in an editor um
and Ken Thompson wrote an editor called
QED which was very very powerful but
these were all totally a command based
they were not most or cursor based
because it was before mice and even
before cursors because they were running
on terminals that printed on paper
okay no no CRT type displays let alone
LEDs and so then when UNIX came along
Ken took QED and stripped way way way
way down and that became an editor that
he called edy and it was very simple but
it was a line oriented editor and so you
you could load a file and then you could
talk about the lines one through the
last line and you could you know print
ranges of lines you could add text you
could delete text you could change text
or you could do a substitute command
that would change things within a line
or within groups of lines they can work
on a parts of a file essentially yeah
your work on any part of it the whole
thing or whatever but it was entirely
command line based and it was entirely
on paper okay paper and that meant that
you've changed yeah right real paper and
so if you changed the line you had to
print that line using up another line of
paper to see what changed cause okay
yeah
so when thing when CRT displays came
along yeah then you could start to use
cursor control and you could sort of
move where you were on the screen in
without reprinting every printing and
one of there were a number of editors
there the one that I was most familiar
with and still use is VI which was done
by bill joy and so that dates from
probably the late 70s as a guess and it
took it full advantage of the cursor
controls I suspected Emacs was roughly
at the same time but I don't know I've
never internalized Emacs so so I use at
this point I stopped using IDI always do
can I use VI sometimes and I you Sam
what I can and Sam is available on most
systems it was it is available you have
to download it yourself from typically
the plan line operating system
distribution it's been maintained by
people there and so I'll get home
tonight I'll try it it's cool it's all
it's a sounds sounds fascinating
although my love is with Lisp and Emacs
have went into that hippie world of
I think it's likes what religion where
you brought up with yes sir
that's right most of the actual program
I had to do is C C++ and Python but my
weird sort of yeah my religious
upbringing is in Lisp so
you